hey guys es alkali antwortet videos bis
wir die hot heads up to cancer support
als inspector very well and concept you
can have to find out farblich checkt
infobox auf das video als switch to
germany
willkommen zurück an einem sonnigen und
windigen mittwoch in berlin
wir sind gerade in einem biergarten und
wir anfragen bekommen deshalb heute mal
wieder ein kari antwortet video
wir haben fragen bekommen nicht von
irgendwem sondern aus moskau von einer
ganzen uni gruppe von schülern und
dozenten und jetzt hören wir die erste
frage was halten die deutschen von
lernvideos auf youtube welche deutsche
lern kanäle sind heutzutage bei der
deutschen jugendlichen besonders beliebt
jannis sagt ich muss das mikrofon
beschützen damit der wind nicht so viel
geräusche macht also die erste frage ist
ein bisschen schwierig zu beantworten
denn ich kann ja nicht für alle
deutschen sprechen und ich gucke keinen
bestimmten kanal für bestimmte
lernvideos außer meinen eigenen aber den
komiker mich aber ich gucke sehr viele
youtube wenn es darum geht bestimmte
fragen zu beantworten das stimmt schon
ich glaube schon dass es populär ist
welche kanäle besonders bei deutschen
jugendlichen beliebt sind ist eine gute
frage es gibt mittlerweile sehr viele
kanäle die auch wissen rund um abitur
wissen und einfach fragen beantworten
zur gesellschaft ich persönlich kenne
mister wissen to go als einen guten
kanal der auch mancher von deutsch
lernen geguckt wird
aber es gibt viele von solchen kanälen
deshalb sollten vielleicht deutscher
jugendlicher das beantworten und nicht
ich denn ich bin jetzt seit dieser woche
34 und das ist wirklich sehr alt also
wenn ihr deutsche seid und jünger
schreib doch mal einen kommentar
dann
freuen sich unsere freunde in moskau und
wissen was ihr so guckt nächste frage
welcher feiertage gibt es in deutschland
im sommer wie feiert man sie feiertage
im sommer gute frage ich kenne nicht so
viele also es gibt schon feiertage so
was wie christi himmelfahrt erster mai
aber es gibt wenig was so richtig
gefeiert wird ich glaube wenn man sehr
katholisch ist dann feiert man schon ein
paar feiertage aber in meinem umfeld
kenne ich niemanden der so katholische
feiertag gefeiert das einzige was ich
für mein freund ist der erste mai erster
mai kann man natürlich entweder
demonstrieren gehen für arbeiter
arbeitnehmerrechte
oder man kann eine tour machen am ersten
mai das ist populär da wo ich herkomme
und wir machen immer eine fahrradtour
grillen und trinken viel wir das ist
unsere dass unsere einzige feiertag im
sommer falls ihr andere feier teil kennt
in deutschland schreibt uns nächste
frage aus moskau bald kommt der sommer
wir wissen dass b gelten in deutschland
sehr beliebt sind könnte die uns über
sieben gartenkultur in deutschland
erzählen ja biergärten sind tatsächlich
populär in deutschland und da kommen wir
auch direkt zum thema in biergärten wird
bier getrunken und ich habe mir dieses
bier nur anlässlich dieses videos geholt
um mit euch anzustoßen
biergärten sind orte wie dieser hier und
wir sind nur wegen der frage jetzt
gerade hier hingegangen um euch zu
zeigen wie das aussieht
jetzt ist es nachmittag aber heute abend
wenn das wetter gut ist wird es hier
sehr voll seien alle tische werden hier
besetzt seien hier sitzen wenn hunderte
leute und sie sitzen einfach gemeinsam
trinken ein bier und essen eine
bratwurst
sauerkraut eine brezel heute
wahrscheinlich dass er es nicht so gut
ich muss das mikrofon wieder verstecken
sagt janisch biergärten sind tatsächlich
populärer in süddeutschland da sitzt man
mehr draußen generell auch unter ist das
meer teil der kultur in bayern
baden-württemberg findet man das oft in
norddeutschland nicht so viel aber hier
in berlin schon und das freut mich
persönlich hier wenn sommer ist
verbringen wir hier sehr viel zeit in
dieser biergarten ist direkt in der nähe
unseres hauses
nächste frage was gefällt sie an der
deutschen sprache besonders was hasen
und besonders liebt was habe ich an der
deutschen sprache liebt also richtig
lieb hab ich eigentlich nichts an der
sprache das ist irgendwie nicht finde
ich kein gefühl was man für die eigene
sprache empfindet aber doch so etwas was
ich gerne mag an der sprache ist wenn
man so ein bisschen undeutlich spricht
das ist etwas was zum beispiel klaus
sehr gerne mache und werner krauß
sprechen
vielleicht ist auch so ein bisschen nur
deutsch so dieser schwierige dialekt so
ein bisschen so ein bisschen vor sich
hin gelagert und man hört dann alles
nicht so deutlich
wir könnten also ein video gucken
vielleicht nennen wir das hier mal ein
mit claus dann könnt ihr mal ein
bisschen darauf achten wie ich mit klaus
rede
das ist ein bisschen anders ein bisschen
undeutlicher das mag ich an der
deutschen sprache aber seitdem ich sie
gern mache rede ich nicht mehr so ich
versuche jetzt deutlicher zu reden
janosch was magst du an der deutschen
sprache ach ja nicht hat gerade gesagt
er mag dass die sprache so deutlich ist
wahrscheinlich mag er
was genau ist dort nicht für dich
die dort aus sprang findet jan
steuerlich ja sie so janitsch mag
deutliche aussprache
ich mag undeutliche aussprache und wind
lässt ihr deutsche zeiten genau die
magazine deutsche zeitungen und magazine
lese ich nicht so viel muss ich sagen
also keine zeitungen mehr die
ausgedruckt in printform vorliegt ich
lese tagesschau.de jeden tag quasi das
ist die das web angebot des öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehens und wie ich finde
auch eine der besten seiten für
nachrichten ansonsten noch spiegel
online
andere seiten man guckt immer mal so
wenn man den nachricht sieht wie wird
das unterschiedlich auf verschiedenen
seiten dargestellt
hauptsächlich lese ich tatsächlich
tagesschau.de und das kann ich auch für
sprach- lern- empfehlen denn da gibt es
relativ kurze artikel und dann könnt ihr
auch mal sehen was in deutschland
eigentlich so in den nachrichten ist
vielleicht die wichtigste
nachrichtenseite in deutschland habt ihr
für uns oder heim tipps wo man am besten
in berlin ausgehen kann
geheimtipps zum aus die amish hast du
geheim tipps zum ausgehen in berlin
einfach berlin-mitte ja ich glaube man
ausgehen
meinst du mehr etwas so bars und clubs
wir gehen tatsächlich nicht so viel aus
wir arbeiten sehr viel und fernseher
wenig wir gehen gerne in bars und den
biergärten da bin ich ein fan von ich
mag sitzen und reden und irgendwo
hingehen wo wir nur irgendwie zum saufen
hingehen habe ich früher gemacht ich
weiß das klingt wahnsinnig langweilig
aber nicht mehr so viel ich mag klubs
nicht so sehr und diese berliner party
kultur den ganzen leuten die aus aller
welt hier nur zum feiern hinkommen und
zum drogen nehmen ist nicht so mein ding
gibt es mentalitätsunterschiede zwischen
menschen aus unterschiedlichen
bundesländern gibt es
mentalitätsunterschiede ja natürlich
gibt es mentalitätsunterschiede sogar
sehr große als
ich würde sagen die menschen in
süddeutschland sind viel offener
freundlicher hat auch was mit der
straßenkultur zu tun mit der biergarten
kultur die menschen sitzen draußen haben
mehr freude am leben finde ich und ich
finde manchmal merkt das wenn man es nur
durch und nach süddeutschland kommt mag
man man merkt diese herzlichkeit und ich
mag das auch sehr dass so ein bisschen
wie wenn man in die usa kommt man wird
erst mal auch angesprochen freundlich
begrüßt für mich gehört das einfach dazu
weinort deutschland ist das nicht so und
ich weiß auch warum das nicht so ist
in köln sind die leute auch sehr
herzlich und berlin ist er so das
gegenteil da ist man eher so rau und
schroff und somit fremden reden ist hier
nicht so populär haben wir in unserem
letzten video auch gezeigt kann man sich
auch daran gewöhnen
warum schreibt man im deutschen normen
groß warum schreibt man deutschen dom
groß weil sie nicht wahrscheinlich wurde
das irgendwann mal so festgelegt von der
kommission die die deutsche
rechtschreibung festlegt aber vielleicht
weiß dass hier jemand von unseren
schlauen zuschauern schreibt uns einen
kommentar selbst japan beim jahr
der versender unserem kind sehen darf
seht ihr fern wenn ja welche sender und
sendungen sind das den fernseher ich
habe zwar einen fernseher aber ich muss
sagen dass ich den selten einschalte
weil das ist irgendwie so ich weiß nicht
ich bin zwar mit fernsehen aufgewachsen
als ich jung war aber heute mache ich
das nicht mehr fernseh gucken ist nicht
mehr so mein ding
ich gucke wohl gerne so bestimmte sachen
in der mediathek oder bei netflix wenn
ich mich darauf freue oder wenn ich
krank bin vor allem auch oder wenn ich
mich immer wirklich entspannen will
ansonsten gucke ich sehr wenig fernsehen
und sehr wenig regelmäßig wenn guck ich
meistens im internet und dann die
sendung die ich gucke sind entweder
informationen und dokus tagesschau gucke
ich zum beispiel dokus bei ard und zdf
den öffentlich rechtlichen sendern titel
thesen temperamente ist eine sendung die
jeden sonntagabend kommt in der es um
ja es geht uns um verschiedene themen
vor allem kultur aber auch politische
themen und das ist eine sendung die mir
sehr gut gefällt mein lieblingssender wo
ich sagen auslandsjournal kann ich noch
empfehlen das sind immer so kurz ihre
beiträge und late night shows gucke ich
generell ist ein genre was ich gerne mag
amerikanische und deutsche jeden tag im
moment amerikanische lake nicht aus
einfach weil es da so viel mehr zu
berichten gibt als in deutschland ist
einfach amerikanische politik ist
einfach wahnsinnig unterhaltsam und das
gucke ich gerne zum frühstück was dann
abends in amerika gelaufen ist und
deutsche late night shows gibt es leider
nicht so viel das einzige was guckt bar
ist also was man gucken kann und wo man
auch spaß bei haben kann ist im moment
dass nero magazin royal die anderen sind
leider nicht
nicht so mein ding muss ich sagen wie
verbringen die deutschen ihren oder
urlaub am liebsten wie verbringen die
deutschen am liebsten ihre ferien
deutsche verreisen unglaublich gern ich
glaube das kann man sagen im vergleich
zu anderen ländern sind wir dafür
bekannt dass wir gerne wegfahren in den
ferien
ich hab jetzt keine zahlen im kopf aber
ich würde so behaupten dass die schon so
20 30 prozent in deutschland urlaub
machen und viele andere auch ins ausland
fahren und da fährt man irgendwo hin wo
es irgendwie was gibt was es in
deutschland nicht gibt nämlich sonne
strand freundliche leute zum beispiel
spanien italien türkei die ganzen
mittelmeer länder sind sehr populär bei
deutschen auch ägypten tunesien die
kanaren siri nicht
und ansonsten auch noch weiter in die
welt je nachdem wie viel abenteuerlust
man hat und was man sich leisten kann
können wir mal ein video zu machen denke
ich demnächst bei easy germany
verbringen deutsche ihren urlaub bin ich
hier jana das war kari antwortet für
diese woche heute mit fragen aus moskau
und zwar von studenten der fakultät für
journalistik
der lomonossow-universität ich hoffe ich
habe das richtig ausgesprochen in moskau
ihr habt uns fragen geschickt sie haben
übrigens auch ein eigenes deutschland
projekt das heißt episch deutsch den
link werden wir mal hier unten posten
könnt ihr mal drauf klicken und sehen
was sie machen sie unterstützen nämlich
russen beim deutsch lernen und wenn ihr
mal eine schulklasse hat und ein paar
fragen schicken möchtet mache das gerne
und natürlich kann jeder von euch fragen
schicken postet sie einfach hier unten
und wenn ich sie beantworten kann dann
versuche ich das gerne
und ja das war's für heute die haben
mich hast du noch was zu sagen großer
jana also normalerweise macht man das in
deutschland nicht dass man jetzt um 15
54 bier trinkt denn in deutschland sagt
man kein bier vor vier nur damit ihr das
wisst prost auf janosch bis zur nächsten
woche